how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we had a really exciting day today we
got a brand new special look at Avengers
in game packed with new footage and of
course Avengers endgame tickets went on
sale this morning at 8:00 a.m. Eastern
Time and with that I'm going to announce
the winner of my IMAX ticket giveaway
congratulations to Rebecca Harris for
being the winner email me in the link in
my description and I'll get you your
prize for the rest of you don't worry
I'm starting a new giveaway giving away
another life-sized Infinity Gauntlet
along with some Avengers in-game art the
same rules apply if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is be subscribed to my channel with
the notifications turned on like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain and also people have been asking
if commenting on each video increases
your chances yes it does as you can see
the way I picked the winner is I pick a
random video that has happened since the
giveaway has started and then I use a
program to pick the winner the program
picks a random comment so the more you
comment the better your chances are so I
hope that helps and again be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so you can enter the new
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway thank you all
so much for participating in the
giveaways and thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]